the Food and Drug Administration is
looking at more aggressive action to
tell women considering breast implants
about the potentially serious risk the
agency proposed yesterday that
manufacturers should print a so-called
black box warning on implant packaging
that warning is the FDA's strongest form
of caution today CBS this morning
consumer investigative correspondent
that's an or Werner is following this
story and and I guess why is the FDA
releasing this these guidelines now well
you know there's been a lot of concern
this move is coming as the agency is
taking a lot of heat from women who say
they weren't warned of potential
complications linked to breast implants
before they had surgery now the black
box warning the FDA is proposing would
lay out those risks those complications
include chronic fatigue joint pain and
even a rare type of cancer called breast
implant associated anaplastic large cell
lymphoma now a large majority of those
cancer cases have been linked to those
rougher textured implants 67% of those
with the disease had textured implants
now while rare that cancer has already
killed 33 women earlier this year one of
the largest manufacturers of breast
implants Allergan volunteer Tara Lee
recalled all of its textured implants
due to the increased cancer risk
Allergan has yet to comment on the FDA's
move one plastic surgeon we talked to
says the obvious problem with the FDA's
proposal is that implants are selected
while the patient is already in surgery
she says many patients never get to see
these products labels unto me until the
implants are already in their bodies so
that's something to consider they're all
talking yes also talking about having a
checklist of informational checklist for
patients that they would ideally go over
with their doctors so that they really
sort of absorb some of the potential
risks here yeah will be very interesting
to see what the implant makers have to
say about this new black box idea Anna
thank you very much